the missile strike that killed arounds
most powerful military leader Qasem
Soleimani marks a dramatic escalation of
tensions between the United States and
Iran the White House and Pentagon
confirmed the killing saying the strike
at Baghdad Airport had been carried out
under a direct order from the president
the u.s. airstrike sparked concerns over
an escalation of regional tensions that
could disrupt crude supplies on news of
the assassination brent crude rose just
over 4% spiking at $69 50 a barrel
that's its highest since mid-september
when Saudi oil facilities were attacked
briefly slashing output in the world's
top exporter by half asian stocks
indices were broadly lower after the air
strike investors turned to safe haven
assets such as gold Swiss francs and
Japanese yen as they braced themselves
for repercussions let's bring in our
financial correspondent Ollie Bart's in
Frankfurt Olli so fears of escalation of
conflict escalation in the region
clearly have investors boot now what
action do you think they want to see
from Iran in the u.s. at this point well
clearly some indication that there's not
going to be the kind of escalation that
people fear and that can get quite out
of hand if one side reacts too quickly
and too harshly
to the other side at the moment I don't
know if that's a very realistic
expectation or hope but certainly that's
what people are having their fingers
crossed for because of course there's so
much at stake there's talk in the market
of quite drastic scenarios a possible
stock market crash of the situation
worsens a possible war and another war
in the Middle East which would of course
dampen
the prospects were all concerned let
alone the prospect of the people in the
Middle East scary scenarios there so do
you think this news will have a lasting
impact on hopes of rebuilding the global
economy after all the havoc wreaked by
these trade bars well let's assume that
this situation stays where it is the oil
prices have risen a bit but they're not
progressing towards $80 or beyond and
there's no war that ensues no no more
fighting no more escalation then of
course you can get back to normal and
say we have progress on us-china trade
and that's very very important for the
worldwide economy and the phase one deal
signing is to be expected on January
15th but of course it hinges on
everything else being in place in the
markets and the economies the people
making decisions in companies not being
worried worried about other things in
the oil price that genell is such a
central element to the world economy
determining how much people make how
much firms make airlines corporations
across the world and how much money
consumers have to spend thank you Willy
Bart's there in Frankfurt for us